one by one we were taken into a room for
like one or two hours where they'd like
pepper us with questions
trying to get us to say that we were
planning to shoot up the school
and we weren't
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who once wrote an anonymous
story
about her friends on fiction press and
then emailed it to them and tried to
pass it off like it was written by a
stranger elise morales
and with us today we have an
emmy nominated comedian and writer he is
currently one of the co-head writers of
full
frontal with samantha bee but before all
of that
he was a graduate of dillard high school
it's mike tucker
hey hello hello
thank you for having me thank you of
course uh what mascot
are we working with at dillard high
school it was
uh it was the black panther really
that's cool it was uh for background of
my high school was actually one of like
the first
uh schools like built for black students
in south florida oh
so it actually has like a lot of civil
rights history and then
i went there and ruined it
so it was like intentionally a cool
black panther for that reason
whenever we kick off the episode i
always like to ask what flavor
of high school was dillard high school
you said south florida it's got this
crazy history
it seems like it's a public school it
was a public school yeah
okay so give us yeah what's the vibe at
dillard
um well i weirdly i weirdly liked high
school
i think because my school had uh it had
a tech program and also had a performing
arts program
um but it also had uh incredible sports
teams like
my high school is i'm not a big sports
fan but it like produces nfl players nba
players
it's a relatively big public school for
sports
um but because of that different
departments
people actually kind of liked each other
like i was never
bullied by jocks uh if there was anyone
i hated it was like
other nerds who were jerks to me so like
it was never like you were actually
competing for the same
like status and stuff the jobs aren't
bothering you really
right like i became friends with some of
the like i actually at one point
was getting paid to help them write
college essays
yes like it wasn't like i'm gonna shove
you in a locker unless you help me was
like i'll give you 50 bucks and i was
like sure i could use 50 bucks
was that the going rate for a paper
i didn't know how much to charge so that
was you know when someone asked you how
much money and you're like i don't know
a hundred dollar
like it's that sort of response and 50
to me seemed very reasonable
yeah 50 is reasonable i think i mean i
guess it depends on the paper because
there are some projects in high school
where it's like
you should be making a full-time salary
to be doing this
right yeah yeah all right so
what uh you're saying you were friends
with kind of
everyone what was teen
might like like let's walk through a
typical day
in teen mike's life um
so i'd uh show up i'd show up to usually
i got there a bit early because i took
the buses to school because i still
don't know how to drive
as a 36 year old man oh wow never
never learned never drove were most
people driving at your high school yeah
i mean um
most people were driving i will say
because it was a relatively big school
you still had a lot of people busing or
walking from the neighborhood because it
was like
smack dab in the middle of the
neighborhood um but yeah it had a
giant parking lot of students cars and i
i sometimes
got rides home with teachers so that was
fun
yeah okay so your team mike is beloved
by all
you've got friends in and the football
team your teachers will let you into
their car
right i was still a miserable person but
overall it wasn't because of other
people it was because of myself
which i can own up to now yeah but that
but at the time you're just kind of like
why is this
why do i feel bad every second of the
day right
or like girls don't like me and like i
i'd be dressed in like a giant tweety
bird shirt and like cotton shorts
and being like i don't understand i'm a
nice guy and i'm like yeah but you you
look like i'm gonna murder someone it
took me so long
yeah that's um that's very true like i
would always be like i'm so
like everybody at this school
thinks that i'm such a freak and then
i'd also be like flying off the handle
in public
every day exactly like why doesn't
anybody get me and i'm like i don't know
you're screaming
some people never have that realization
though they spend their whole life being
like i was oppressed
and some people aren't high school but
others yes it's a choice
yeah there's you have to eventually
overcome your high school experience
for the most part if it's in the realm
of normal high school experiences you
have to find a way
to come become bigger than that but i
think i think
i think eve on the other side too if
it's like super good
i think you also need to overcome that
like whatever nothing makes me feel
sadder than someone who's like
best memories are from high school no
and it's okay to like
have had fun i had a fun time in high
school i have pleasant memories but you
want to
college should be more fun than high
school yes
number one like it's for being more fun
it definitely should be your 20s should
be more fun than high school
i agree yeah it's it's so weird to me
when people are like if i could go back
to any time my life
it'd be those high school days i'm like
really when you had to wake up at
six and do like eight hours of work ah
come on like homework like homework like
math not just your job
no so what classes did you what were
your classes that you liked
um i really liked my computer
programming classes and
but the reason is because the teacher
was
uh an alcoholic and at one and early on
he just ghosted the class
and occasionally they'd have a southern
but he kind of ghosted so much that they
just didn't address it
so we had these relatively new computers
in this computer lab with 20 people and
we honestly just played video games
for an hour every day because this dude
was gone now we didn't learn anything
we didn't learn a thing but it was super
fun for two years to just play video
games for an hour a day oh my god and so
you
you got in like you did one year and
then you could take it again
you could take programming too yeah uh
that's see
i feel like i feel like when you're in
high school
or middle school whatever when you get
into a class and you realize like
oh this is one of the one this is one of
the ones where we don't have to do
anything
it's like the best it's the best it's
the best feeling
you like forge incredible friendships in
those classes
i feel like me and another guy were the
experimental class for like
the first teleteaching class that my
school did
and so it was it was actually calculus
and
the guy was teaching at another school
and there was like a couple students at
each school
but the technology at that point was
still super young so they could only see
like they didn't have like you know grid
view so they can only see the last
students to talk so what we realized
early on was if we don't talk we can
[ __ ] around and he won't see us and then
when he calls us we'll just
return to the class like we'll just
start paying attention again
yeah so you could do kind of whatever as
long as you were silently
exactly so it was was it was the setup
it was just you
and another guy like sitting and
watching a screen
exactly it was uh it was like in a
library one of the
like library not conference rooms but
you know where they have like ap test
kind of little library rooms and um
they had like a tv setup with a webcam
and it was very fancy they were very
excited about it and it was cool like
the technology worked which is crazy for
like 2002.
yeah i'm like this is zoom school before
zoom school
right wow right but clearly we didn't
it clearly it didn't work as intended
because we just
we figured out a loophole day two no i
it was so interesting because i feel
like i i was in like middle and high
school
in the early 2000s too and i feel like
we got to see the onset
of like smart boards and all this weird
technology but like
also our teachers did not know how to
use them
and so it was like some of your classes
had those like transparencies where you
would just write
and draw on them and some of them it
would be like five minutes of the
teacher trying to get the smart board to
like connect
different smart pens
um i also feel like i live i lived
through the age of teachers who
like were just learning about powerpoint
and thought that if you put every lesson
into powerpoint it would make it
better somehow yes yeah like or like
don't do your science fair project on a
board do it in powerpoint it's like
okay sure but it this is this program
isn't hard this isn't a job skill you're
teaching me
yes they really i we were definitely the
dawn of the multimedia presentation
being required as like a child what were
your like
early websites your high school like
let's say teen
mike is getting on the computer like
what what's he where is he logging in
um i was early aol so this was more
middle school than
this was like early middle school not
high school um i was
in an anne rice fan forum i was in like
a lot of gothy stuff so a lot of vampire
stuff um
not so much music i'm not like the
hugest music person
in terms of like fandom but like a lot
of gothy stuff horror movies i was very
into those chat rooms and forums um
there was a lot of japanese role-playing
sites so things like the square enix fan
site who i later met the creator of
and who was confused as to why i knew
who he was
you're like no you don't understand i'm
exactly the person who knows who you are
you're andrew vestal i put fan fiction
on your site okay
all right thanks man thanks um
yeah fan fiction stuff star wars stuff
like really fandom type stuff i wasn't
into news at that point
and i kind of feel like there wasn't
enough like like we had things like
encarta
on cd but there wasn't as much learning
online as there is now
yeah i i mean i was into fan fiction so
what uh
but i was only into the harry potter fan
so how like how involved in
the fandoms were you getting like how
much time would you say you were
investing online in them
um i would say i was probably investing
just as much time as i was spending on
the actual media itself
so like you know if i if i if it took
took me like 50 hours to be at a final
fantasy game i was definitely spending
50 hours
on a site talking about it arguing about
it mostly just arguing arguing about
what it meant
arguing about meanings which is dumb
because i have a master's in english lit
and i wrote a book about what a video
game means
but still when i was 13 i was like you
don't get what final fantasy 7 is about
so mostly arguing with other people uh
because i don't know if this
this maybe you know different fandoms
are different levels of toxicity
but like people at this point would like
they would both be very like welcome to
the community oh fandom but then you'd
have like one person every fanfiction's
like this is terrible they'd never do
this and you're like it doesn't
it doesn't matter they're having sex who
cares why are you
i know i remember i remember like when i
was writing fanfiction for harry potter
and all of it was bad and like it was
all just like
it was literally a character that was
obviously me and i was just at hogwarts
and like everyone wanted to date me and
that was the fan fiction and that's what
i was doing
and i would get flamed by obvious real
adults
and i'm like
they would be like this story [ __ ]
sucks like you're living out a fantasy
of like
literally they would like read me in
these comments and i'm like okay well
i'm a 12 year old who loves writing
yeah and you're ruining my life
horrible right oh my god they're like
they people were so intense about that
stuff because they really like everyone
was so attached to those characters that
it was like
no you can't no you don't understand
cloud strife
yes and i mean that's obviously still
happening
to young children today who dare to post
things online
do you remember like any early internet
arguments you got into or any early like
squabbles
um i did i i tweeted about this recently
but i was kicked out of that anne rice
forum
because i had a very very passionate
argument and i should say at the time i
was very gothy when i was
13 but i was also still kind of
religious as a catholic i wasn't like
one of those catholics on twitter now
that's
in [ __ ] sane but i was definitely
still very catholic
yeah um the goth aesthetic and catholic
catholicism like they go well they're
yeah
they go very well yes um i see a
connection
so i was a big fan of anne rice and i
did not pick up on any of the horniness
of those stories like now
when i see the movie or when i read the
books they're extraordinarily horny
they're extraordinary extraordinarily
there's so much horniness in them but
kind of responsible for the overall
horniness that vampire
have in the culture now i mean vampires
were always horny but i think the modern
horny vampire is directly
contributed to these books um
but but to me like they were just like
cool books about these like cool
characters
and so i got into a passionate argument
with more than one person
saying because they you know most of the
people in these forms were
probably adults in their 20s 30s or 40s
because anne rice
you know uh goes a bit older and
people talk about sex or they talk about
like wanting to have sex with this
character like i wish i could
[ __ ] lestat and i jumped into where i'm
like well they wouldn't need to have sex
because you don't need to have sex to
reproduce when you're a vampire and
i believed this i i was i wasn't just
trying to troll
i was certain of this and certain about
a thing that doesn't exist but certain
it was a fact
this fictional vampire would never
[ __ ] ever it's gross
so and then again i wondered why i was
lonely for a
long time that is really one of the most
uh
virginal things i've ever heard and it's
really
uh let's continue to walk through teen
mike's day because i feel like we got to
you arrive at school i arrive at school
you arrive at school
um who's the first person you say like
what up to
uh usually first person i say what up to
is
uh a guy named uh raph his full name's
raphael uh he was on my bus route and we
were sort of
bus friends and i i you know i even
though i got along with most people i
wasn't
best friends with a lot of people i was
still very shy and i was still very
awkward
i just wasn't really like attacked for
that
uh yeah so so i didn't have a ton of
friends so i was really close friends
with him so we would hang out
and um so we would usually head to the
high tech office first because we'd get
about a half an hour before the bell and
there wasn't really like my school
didn't have like that long
hallway of lockers thing like we had
lockers but they were sort of like
scattered there wasn't one congregation
point yeah go to the high tech office uh
where a bunch of like sort of nerdy
people would hang out like we play like
like people would
bring video game systems too and we
played them in the morning
and wow so like people would bring a
dreamcast
uh ps2 when that finally came out and so
we play like fighting games for half an
hour in the high tech office
uh and we talked to miss milie was the
lead was the head of the department she
was also my middle school
social studies teacher so i knew her
from before she was one of the people
who would drive me home sometimes wow
shout out miss million
miss millie um
uh still still the person like when i
post something nice on facebook and she
likes it i'm always like that's miss
millie
yeah it's like oh that's a good one yeah
but if it's like a family member i'm
like i don't know
whatever um i didn't know you could see
my page
oh god i forgot to hide you from my page
um so yeah we'd go there and usually you
know then
sort of go through the flow of classes
uh
english uh socials i went through i did
ap classes although
our ap classes weren't that good like i
think our ap
classes were basically as the normal
classes are full
like like our ap history teacher
um whose name i won't say cause i don't
know if she's alive or not um
would tell us the moon landing was fake
whoa
yeah is that like some florida [ __ ] or
what's going on there
i think i think it's i think it's
florida public school stuff i mean i
also had some amazing teachers but you
know this teacher she would like
whenever we got to something in the
history book that she thought
didn't really happen she would like let
us know that it didn't
like she would i don't think she would
be a q anon person but i think if there
was like
she would be like price is right as
close as you can go without going over
you know what i mean like yeah
like she believed the moon landing was
fake she had i forget what it was but
she had a weird theory about the vietnam
war
like it like it either didn't happen or
it like
ended before it did she had a conspiracy
theory that i'd never heard before
since about it it ended but early it was
something
it was something where she was like
don't trust this when we were reading
about the vietnam war
and it wasn't about like wealth
disparity or the race gap in the war
because we brought that up like the
reasons for getting into the war
like right what actually went on on the
ground
she was very certain that some the
government had been lying about it
did she what was her kennedy theory or
did she
she didn't have a candidate she didn't
have it was weird
like some things you would be like the
like no kennedy but moon
like things that naturally flow into
each other so she would teach the jfk
seven she would be like and then
he was killed by leave harvey oswald and
that's right sort of who did it
and it didn't be like but the vietnam
war exactly but like
that is what it seems it
was so we didn't like like um again my
ap
those programming classes programming
two was ap programming
and dude never showed um like i would
say
i if you look at my ap scores you could
tell the classes where teachers tried
because like
english and social studies i got fives
and calculus
programming and uh history which was
different than
government i got uh government i got a
five history i got a
two uh i feel like there's like a
pivotal moment as a teenager when you
realize that your teacher
like oh my teacher is bad or like oh my
teacher is a psycho
or like or really dumb or just anything
like realizing that they're real people
and that means that they can also be bad
at their job or be totally
crazy and i i remember like just
a couple teachers in high school where i
was like
oh you're you're not
here with us
i remember i had one chemistry teacher
who was extremely against
sustainable energy to
like literally would not stop telling us
how ugly windmills were
like before donald trump was saying like
windmills give you cancer or whatever
i'm pretty sure this woman said it in my
chemistry class
my uh ap government teacher was very
against unions
and he was i will weirdly say he was
very hardcore republican
but he like taught the subject well like
we walked away knowing how the
government worked
but all of his opinions on how it worked
were awful
but since florida's a right to work
state all like i would say
whenever we talk about like the
economics or like or like you know
lobbyists or labor unions he hated labor
unions he hated labor unions
so much he like would talk about he
would talk [ __ ] about the other teachers
at our school who were like
activists within the teachers like he
was it was almost like he was mad at us
that other teachers were in a union
it really is like it's interesting when
when your teacher brings their [ __ ]
into the classroom and you're like oh
you're
something's going on with you yeah yeah
like
like oh you you have a personal issue
that's now
becoming everyone's problem
there was a one teacher that was that
was like good friends with another
and we joked that they were having an
affair and they were like they were like
please stop that we're not having an
affair
and they weren't but that teacher was
having an affair with a different
teacher
but it was so funny how did it come out
like that the teacher was having the
other affair
um he got shortly after
we shortly after i graduated he got
divorced and then
married that teacher but it happened it
happened quick enough
where you're like you you were having an
affair yeah it's like
i don't know i don't know did you would
you meet the day after the divorce
right exactly going on here you like met
the day after i got married six months
after that
that's fast this is a question i love to
ask
do you remember any big scandals
controversies or anything of the like
from your high school
um we uh we
i mean we we had things we had like a
couple kids
die one kid went on the roof because
they repainted
uh part of the roof of the school he
went up there to huff the paint and then
he died of
uh heat exposure or heating um
oh oh
we we actually had one the i was i was
weirdly involved
in a strange controversy right after
columbine
every security guard at every school
like wanted
to like catch someone so they could be
you know in the newspapers like we had i
forget the security guards name but we
had a security guard who was like
he was almost like a villain in a
cartoon who's trying to constantly catch
you kids
yes and so obviously after columbine
uh the focus shifted to uh lonely gothy
kids
and hard time for y'all hard time for
y'all
hard time for us uh the worst time for
us and so
he like a couple of us got like rounded
up
and it wasn't that we we hadn't done
anything really i think like one or two
of us had like
written poems that were kind of gothy
for class but it wasn't like
a threatening violent poem it was just
like i embrace death
which everyone writes yeah uh
2002 who's not embracing
death we were like we were brought into
a room and like
not like interrogated like we were
beaten or something but like kept in a
room
like individually by ourselves not with
the other like students but like one by
one we were taken into a room for like
one or two hours where they'd like
pepper us with questions
trying to get us to say that we were
planning to shoot up the school
and we weren't the things none of us
none of us had the capability of doing
that none of us had the weapons
uh they ended up calling our parents
where they're like we think they're
planning to like do something at the
school
and all of the parents were more
confused than anything because it just
didn't make any sense
um but it became this controversy
because like for a while the guard was
like we need to expel them we need to
send a message
and based on nothing based on nothing
and a lot of because again we were like
nerdy gothy kids
you know we we they were gonna expel you
for being goth
right like unbelievable the worst of us
was an [ __ ] who like
made wise cracks at teachers you know
what i mean like he was like
the c student who's like i'm gonna dick
but like no one was violent no one
but it was this crazy thing where like
you had it felt like very
again now it's doesn't seem like the
biggest deal but at the time it felt
very like the crucible where i was like
but i didn't do this
i'm i'm the valedictorian of the school
like it was like so
like because i was like what does this
mean do i not go to college now
do i just do well yeah i mean it's it's
a really
um it's a really lofty accusation it's
really heavy and i imagine as a kid it's
really confusing to just have like
authority figures pull you into an
office say you're doing something
you have no intention of doing you
wouldn't even know where
to begin doing right and then they just
are rolling forward with the accusation
that's so wild
yeah they were like they were they were
so certain it didn't
amount to anything but it was it
honestly like
and this sounds melodramatic but it
broke a couple of my friends two of my
friends who went through it dropped out
and joined the military
like because of it they were like they
were like i don't want to be here i'm
just gonna go get a job somewhere
and you know my school wasn't a rich
school by any means so
the military was the other option for a
whole lot of students at my school
so there were people who were like [ __ ]
this place i'm just going to join you
guys
i mean it it makes perfect sense because
how can you
feel safe at your school after that
after being like pulled in and just
based on
literally zero evidence except that
you are cause which is crazy
it it really feels like you guys were
the victims of kind of
the moral panic of that time around just
like because i feel like every school
had like a kid who wore a trench coat
and everyone's like
what's his deal and it's like he's
wearing a trench coat is
what his deal is right it's yeah we all
like the matrix a little too much
yeah yeah um and it felt like these
schools didn't know
what to do with like
any uh like they wanted to you they
wanted to protect the school
but they didn't know how and also no one
wanted to just like
pass like gun reform laws so
instead it's like expel the goths
but it really was and
i feel like they had yet to get to the
point that people are at now where it's
like i don't know if it's gonna happen
sooner or later
like it's it's so much more relaxed like
but um yeah it really was a moral panic
like i remember like everyone being like
you know this was caused by video games
and music and then later on you just
find out that
the dudes were terrible people yeah and
like
no they were abused or whatever
i mean like they were they just had
other [ __ ] going on
sometimes people are crazy we just
should just not let them have weapons
uh okay so
you know what that's also interesting
because it surprises me that your school
let you guys play
like violent video games at school
because i feel like that was another big
uh moral panic of that time
i think uh to their credit i think a lot
of the the high tech teachers
were themselves a bit like more nerdy or
you know felt a little more of an
affinity for us so they were cool with
it and they those were the only places
we were doing it there's definitely
teachers who if they knew we were
playing like
mortal kombat whatever number was then
like they would have been furious and
i'm sure that they would have written a
very strong letter to the principal
they would have been outraged all right
outraged i believe it is time for us to
look through
some of these photos uh you sent some
amazing photos
uh here we have you as a baby
i love when people send a baby photos
very cute
so many curls i know uh
as we'll see later that became a problem
but from age
from age like zero to seven the curls
really worked in my favor
look at that that's a cute kid could
have turned wearing a don carter
bowling alley shirt which i just
realized for the first time in 30 years
um very adorable kid did not this could
be a baby
gap kid yeah i was a cute baby for a
short period of time i guess most babies
are only babies for a short period of
time but
get what i mean you were a cute baby for
the period of time
all right let's but let's so let's go on
the journey now
so cute baby what do we have next
up here okay here we go yep
so i are these your siblings those are
my siblings that's my older sister
tiffany and my younger sis
younger brother daniel you are dressed
like the dad in a sitcom
each of us look like we're a different
religion in this photo
yes wow oh my god yes
like that is very true um
my mom uh for for like 15 years was very
into like
southwestern style type imagery and
stuff
and so i think that bled into a lot of
the clothes that she would buy for us
um yes because your sister looks like
she's
mormon maybe and then you look like an
adult man celebrating christmas
and my brother i feel like your brother
looks like a nice jewish boy
he does he does he got yeah honestly
though to be accurate my father's jewish
and he got like
all of that look he got oh my gosh
blue collared shirt yeah he has the
i mean he's the star of the photo in
many ways but he has the most normal
attire on here
yeah he he yeah he was the one who was
born
after my parents figured out to stop
doing certain things
so is this a typical like would a loud
sweater like this be a be typical of
your would you wear this to school
um no i'd probably wear this to
something like church or if we were
going to like grandma's
uh if she was like holding passover or
something um
so that was like that was like a dress
shirt for me
okay orchard yeah yeah
it it is and it was um
but uh yeah it was terrible i hated it
that was
in the south florida sun any any time i
had to dress up like i
i didn't hate going to church because i
was like this is [ __ ] man like i
realize now
it is but like as a kid i hated going to
church because i had to wear like
a shirt over a shirt yeah i feel like
this is a tight
fitted like thick button-up shirt that
you do not
need to be wearing in florida not at all
not at all
um no to school normally i just wear
like a t-shirt of
whatever cartoon i was watching at that
point um a lot of pinky in the brain a
lot of taz
and this was not bringing in the ladies
you said this wasn't bringing in the
ladies
um despite despite writing very long
handwritten notes asking people out i
rarely got a date wow who okay
you have to tell me about the note um
how did this note happen
how did you deliver it there's more than
one note there's more than one note that
this happened with
the standard uh the standard of it was
i would completely fall in love with
someone usually someone who was who was
nice to me for like five minutes and
so i would like i would i would you know
get to know them and i would be friendly
with them it wouldn't be a friend zone
type thing it would be more like
classmates who talk you know i wouldn't
i was never someone who'd get like
deeply deeply involved
i would kind of like fall in love from a
distance get friendly with them
and usually i'd write like a long note
that was kind of like
very a little too soul-bearing like it
wouldn't be like
a little much up top
we don't need to put it all out there
quite right so early
i would put it all out there i would
like make these like promises like i'm
going to make you live forever
like like so many things so many big
swings and
to their credit like like most of them
turned me down very nicely like most of
them
like some would write a note back that's
like thank you so much i
apologize i don't feel this way like it
was all me
like as much as i want to be angry at
the women who rejected me they were
great about a horrifying situation
but that was very scary how would you
how would you deliver the letter what
was your tactic for
oh here you go can you read this later
literally in person delivery not like
put like in the locker
or backpack pocket or something you know
what
i i respect that though because if
you're gonna write if you're gonna write
the soul bearing letter you have to be
able to deliberate yourself
yeah yeah i didn't i didn't want to go
the secret admirer route because because
like i was like oh this person will
definitely date me after they find out
how deep i am
did any of did any of the letters work
um no i actually started getting to go
out with girls in high school after i
after i realized uh i didn't need to do
that
and became more human like and i stopped
acting like a [ __ ] ferengi
like i started to like you know people
would be like like like my nickname
in the back half of high school was
jetpack and the reason it was jetpack
was because i asked out
this student marcy who was very
beautiful and we went out a couple times
and so
it was said that i was jet packing above
my level oh wow
and we never like i think we like
you know kissed on the lips but not like
made out
i think that was as far as it went was
like a peck on the lips but
it was after i learned that like you
could just be like oh hey do you want to
see a movie
like you could just do that you didn't
think um
what spawned that realization
and how did you get from like oh i love
you to asking out this like
very pretty girl um so
this is a super embarrassing story but
one person i asked out
was very freaked out by me asking her
out and so she went to
the guidance counselor of the school and
she wasn't like it's sexual harassment
throw him out but she was like this is
concerning and again this was around the
same time as the columbine stuff where
if you get a disturbing note
you might go to somebody again she did
the right thing
again and and we've got there's
anti-goth bias
yeah it's out there in the media at the
time
and uh the guidance counselor was
actually like he was kind of like don't
do this sort of thing like he wasn't
like
he wasn't like don't do this you're in
trouble he's like hey man i know what
you're going through
this you know i know it's a hard time
for you right now you don't want to do
this
like you like he wasn't like here's how
you get here's how you get laid man but
he was very like
this is this is a lot of pressure to put
on somebody
uh that you don't know that well and i
was like oh okay
like he guided you in a real way
and it worked and then you and then you
were better for it and you had a more
successful love life as a result
and like well that's beautiful yeah like
immediately
apparently when you don't terrify people
they're more likely to go on a date with
you
yeah and apparently when you just like
sit a young man down and explain to him
calmly how things work he moves forward
in his life yeah sometimes sometimes
sometimes yeah i can't say we you're
right that we can't say always
but i'm heartened by this by this story
of your guidance counselor guiding you
on a better path
and it working yeah yeah it was it was
it you know it wasn't like i mean and
like in my head i was like oh yeah i
guess that makes
you know like when someone explains
something to you we're like i see where
you're coming from
um oh i guess i was being kind of scary
oh and then like it sinks in what you've
been doing where you're like oh
no yeah that's also a horrible moment
the realization of what you've been up
to
it's like oh no all right let's look
through the rest of these photos
cool okay here we have uh
you what are you trying to make this
face in all your photos is this
here's something i am so bad at smiling
on command
like there's something about it like
when someone's like if
someone takes a normal photo and i'm i
can smile normally but when someone's
like everybody smile
i'm like uh i don't know how to do it
yeah you do
look in both photos so far you've been
looking directly like down the barrel
and also you look
so horrified you're promising
it's like i hated getting my photo taken
especially like i hated my body my dad
my dad also like
loved taking photos so this would like
anything like this would be like one or
two hours of him like
posing us different uh putting us in
different like turn to the side and look
at the camera
like he do a fun one and so
i hated it i was outside in an over in
two layers which i hated and i hated
taking photos so
this whole time i'm just like i'm
smiling take my photo but the more
that i was frustrated the less i was
smiling which would make my dad take
more photos
uh your brother has really nailed the
like
you just caught me mid uh happy
jump like your your brother is a natural
in this whole thing and you look so
and my sister looks like not like not a
woman but like a man on a romance novel
cover
yeah you know yes the long hair that
her hair is actually like perfect for
like the guy who's on the horse
is about to like lift you
you beautiful reader onto the horse all
right let's look through these next ones
as well
okay i think the jacket is a good
fashion moment here
it is not a bomber jacket that's
happening where
are you why do you look so miserable i
am uh i am at my i forget where the ice
skating rink was i want to say
sunrise florida but i am at an ice
skating rink birthday party for my
brother
i remember being miserable at it i feel
like i got into a fight with
my dad like an argument with my dad
right beforehand
i forget why i was miserable i just
remember being super miserable
and so whenever anyone tried to take a
photo i was like i'm not even going to
[ __ ] give you a smile
um which though resulted in honestly the
best photo of me that will ever be taken
it's incredible there's no wrong part of
it
everything the netting in the back the
trash can me holding a styrofoam cup
like my hand back like i look like a 47
year old mother of five
you um i was gonna say that you look
like one of tony soprano's friends
it's so good i'm here to make sure
nothing happens at the uh
i'm a blue collar guy and i'm over it
100 i think we have some more good
fashion moments
coming okay so this is the same same
same birthday party
uh as you can tell that jacket's from
epcot center
wow okay i actually do feel like do you
have that
jacket yesterday you could sell that on
a vintage store
at like out of you could be making money
on that jacket
i could weirdly i found some clothes
when i was cleaning out
my parents garage that i had when i was
around this age and
i now weigh as an adult man a little
less than i did then
and so like it was weird to like put on
like a maple wood elementary school
t-shirt and be like oh this
this fits me now i mean
listen all of that style is coming back
you can rock it i crack all your maple
wood elementary school gear
yeah but this jacket actually you could
get a pretty penny for that and what's
going on with the gloves
um i think honestly just skating rink so
i'm sure like my hands were cold and
okay yeah okay got it got it
and here we go again
looking like an adult man
oof um yeah unwrapping dungeons and
dragons board game
right behind me unwrapping nightmare
which is a board game that uses a vhs
cassette
so wow yeah how did it use the vhs
you'd put it in the player and
occasionally it would be like
it was more like a timer that would come
in with certain things where it was like
now everybody do this
um it was supposed to give it like a
spooky element
uh yes most of these i would play with
my brother
or by myself
okay yeah but dungeons and dragons you
can't play by yourself
no but i would like i liked like using
the maps and i liked sort of writing
adventures
and uh yeah i'm i feel like i'm
depressed
realizing how depressing that was was
like i'd pull out the maps and read the
books then put the maps away and put the
books away
it honestly is it is particularly sad
because it's like the point of dungeons
and dragons is like everyone
the thing that makes it good is like
everyone gets together and it's like a
fun
thing and it creates camaraderie among
the these groups and you're like i'll
just be looking at the maps
i don't need the camaraderie i
will take it from here such a lonely boy
did you have a group that you played
with at this time
um i did a little bit after this i think
maybe
two or three that was another thing
about high school is because there was a
fair amount of nerdy people
not even in the tech program just in
general like we did dragon ball z role
playing games we did dungeons and
dragons we did vampire the masquerade
so i finally got to do that stuff when i
got to high school
yeah it seemed like you had a lot going
on i did i
i i high school was definitely far from
the best years of my life
but i i remember it fondly yeah it seems
like you had like an active
life of things i did to keep to keep
everything together all right let's look
at this next photo
is this you and your brother me and my
brother wearing
uh my brother is into sports but my
dad's strategy when i was a kid
um was he knew i didn't like sports that
much i didn't
i hated sports at the time now i don't
hate sports yeah but at that time i was
very like that [ __ ]
like sports ball nerd who like made fun
of it oh
same as same i would be like oh my god
all of like
like the cheerleaders are so stupid what
are they gonna do
and then now i'm like i watch cheer and
i'm like these are
the most brilliant i've ever seen in my
entire life
um but my dad would buy me sports shirts
and be like well maybe if
i make him wear enough like miami heat
shirts and miami dolphin shirts in
florida modeling church he'll eventually
like sports right
and that didn't happen um this photo
is fascinating first of all i just again
like i always look like
a mom like i look like i sort of look
like a mom who gave up
yeah and just my arm around my brother
who's so much more charismatic than me
and so much better on camera and so much
more fun is like look at how sad i look
versus
how much fun he's had you it well it's
interesting because in every photo he's
doing something and you are holding
completely still and staring at the
camera
like every photo he's like in motion
joyful whatever and you are just like
staring at the camera holding yourself
completely still
yep yep no smile nothing did not want a
photo of me taken so i will stare at you
until it's over
i'm gonna make this unpleasant for both
of us yeah
i'm gonna burn it down all right let's
go
okay is this mom this is mom that is my
mom
uh also does not like being photographed
yeah like i see where you
okay i'm seeing where you are getting
some of this and what are you doing in
the back there
i think i'm trying to get ketchup out
onto a burger i
assume that must be seconds before i got
it on myself like there's no other way
it really looks like you're setting it
up and what do you know what shirt that
is
that uh looks like a chicago bull shirt
which i'm sure my dad got me because i
know
that this photo is in chicago from when
i was visiting relatives
oh okay because i was like oh i thought
we were getting all miami shirts
my parents my parents are originally
from chicago they just moved to
florida in the early 80s so my dad did
that thing where he's like when i'm in
chicago i love the cubs when i'm in
florida i love the marlins
that's like kind of how my dad is too
yeah he has no allegiance to any team
all right let's go to the next photo
yeah wow
okay where is this and i notice again
you are wearing
a sports shirt or is this is this on the
same trip
no uh just a different sports related
shirt
yeah i also like that my brother's
wearing a phoenix sun shirt i don't know
why
um your brother again looks adorable
yeah
yeah and i look like i
just got divorced after 30 years of
marriage and i'm back on tinder like i
look like a little bit like
like like sort of a sly smile yes
this one the smile in this one is
interesting it's a little cheekier
what is the giant um tyrannosaurus rex
in the background
uh as it says it's recycle soros i
believe
i barely remember it but i believe that
florida had sort of this
it was either florida or maybe it was in
illinois i forget but there was a museum
that sort of had a whole exhibit on
recycling and i believe this was it
because i remember the exhibit and i
remember this
and there were you remember the recycle
saurus yeah
i remember a big exhibit on recycling
and the dinosaur so in my head they must
go together
yeah um
it's very it's just very funny to me to
name something recycled it's like a sort
of slave
it's so lazy just name it like recycle
soar
even like you think i'm just try i feel
like we could just be trying
a little harder no um all right let's
look
okay and then what is this a yearbook
page that we have
here yep uh senior photo is in
obviously the lower part and then i was
uh most academic
i was most academic so is that you
winning most academic in the middle
that's me and
uh carol white who also won most
academic and that was the two of us
most academic at dillard high school
with a solar system shirt
corduroy pants that made the most sound
in the world when i walked
like would just make all the sound when
i walked i don't think this angle is
doing you any favors that they took this
picture at
i don't think it's right for them to
have taken this from below
and put you in the foreground and this
girl in the background
i don't think that was right that they
did that to you carol white who was much
a thousand times thinner and much
smaller than i am
yeah they put her behind you and back
and then they took the photo from down
below you in front they did you dirty
that day mike
they did they did but you know also
remember putting on a watch because they
wanted me to look
they thought my arms looked weird so
they gave me a watch to put on
okay weird in what way and how did the
watch fix it
i think because it just looked weird to
have like this arm doing nothing
on that oh and so they're like oh if we
add a watch it looks a little more like
i don't know
visually maybe your arm was blending
into the book blending into your pants
or something
that might be that might but all of this
could have been fixed by putting her in
the front
yeah of course yeah but you know why
would you do that
all right mike i feel like we're coming
to the end here so we always like to
round out the pod by asking this
question uh which is if you could talk
to teen mike today
what would you tell him uh what would i
tell
um i would uh that's a tough question i
would i
this sounds like i'm doing a bit i would
honestly probably tell him to like
exercise more i feel like that helped me
so much in college when i started doing
that but in high school i was always
like people should accept me for who i
am
which is true but i was also
keep that right right right but i also
wasn't helping them
like what i they i expected them to
accept me for me doing minimal effort
while they did more than me
um so i probably tell myself to like
be healthier and to get in shape and
it'd also make my life much better uh
i also think that like i tell them that
like don't like the hair thing was never
good
it never went the way i wanted and so
i'm one of like the eight people in the
world where going bald like made me look
better as a human being and so i would
be like the hair thing's not gonna be a
problem
uh yeah don't worry don't worry that's
not gonna be an issue
don't worry uh and also uh don't get
married when you're 25.
okay okay that is awesome very sound
advice because that that will last a
year and a half
and that's for a different podcast it's
a different podcast mike thank you so
much for coming on the show it was great
having you and for
everyone listening at home this has been
the roast of your teenage self podcast
[Music]
you